This is how I met my brothers.
And how we became family.
It's way bigger than basketball.
It was us against everybody.
People think they know my story...
but this is how it all began.
A lot of memories in this gym.
Absolutely, man.
How we put banners up, how we win ball games.
What's crazy is, the practices may have went even harder.
But that's what made the games so easy, bro.
That family bond...
lasts for a lifetime.
We in it together.
We going down or we going up.
Most of the time, we going up.
This is my story.
My story.
This is our story.
Everybody is special in their own way,
but then when you put us together we're like a superhero or--
We're like Captain Planet, cuz
when we put them rings together.